all right here with reaction two of the
lawmakers who wrote the letter to the
Attorney General jeff Sessions
congressman Andy Gibb's and congressman
Matt gates congressman gates we start
with you let's talk about this letter
this is important
absolutely Sean and in the swamp of
Washington DC
Andy McCabe was one of the Loch Ness
monsters and there is a report in final
form prepared by the Office of
Professional Responsibility that details
the basis for firing Andy McCabe and we
believe that the Judiciary Committee and
that the American people should see it
because when we synthesize this report
with what we've learned in congressional
investigations about Andy McCabe's
office potentially being the very place
that Peter struck and Lisa page hatched
their insurance policy when we saw the
emails from Andy McCabe saying that the
Hillary Clinton email investigation
would not be conducted by the Washington
field office but it would instead be be
sent up to headquarters for James Comey
and Andrew McCabe and struck and Paige
to do their deep swamp activities this
is information we've got to know because
it's going to help us find the other
swamp creatures that need to be driven
out of town potentially in handcuffs
congressman well you sound like a
reporter you're ending your report back
to you shot in the studio but well said
I'm not I'm just messing around with you
but congressman big this is too
important let's get to what you're
saying yeah let's let's be honest here
we have people being charged and
indicted by Muller for these processed
crimes or for lying to the investigators
in the Muller investigation and that's
what happened here with McCabe and so
not only is he the center of the whole
thing going back at Hillary Clinton's
investigation but then he comes up and
he's lying and he gets terminated for
that and now the the other side the
press is out there saying oh this is a
you know he just needed a few more hours
until he could get his his pension
that's not what's important what's
important is he be treated just like any
other person in America where we're a
rule of law country and he needs to
adhere to the rule of law just like
everyone else and congressman gates why
is there the mysterious reluctance and
resistance of especially rod Rosen Stein
why is there this resistance he was
begging when when Devin Nunez had
subpoena
the documents he's begging in the final
hours oh please congressman Ryan Mr
Speaker don't turn over this information
let's not let the American people see
about how corrupt the FISA warrants were
in the case of of Carter page in the
Trump campaign and oh we didn't tell the
judge that Hillary paid for Russian lies
in the process and that became the basis
not only for the original application
but for subsequent applications on three
occasions and by the way rod Rosenstein
approved one of them at least maybe two
and he's the guy that then appoints
Muller if that's not a conflict I don't
know what is
well you're right Sean and there is a
troubling allergy at the Department of
Justice when it comes to transparency
they're fighting against every effort by
the Congress to show the American people
what's really happening we've requested
more than 1.3 million records in the
Judiciary Committee we've gotten only
about 3,000 of them so far but this
should not be in dispute this is not a
draft work product this is a final
report that indicates that the Deputy
Director of the FBI had engaged in such
political hackery
that he had to be fired before his own
resignation to suggest that that's not a
document that the American people
deserve to see is ludicrous and it's
this type of stonewalling that has
eroded the trust of the American people
and some of the very folks that we need
to be able to rely on most to keep the
rule of law sacred and preserved in the
United States all right congressman I
got to thank you both for what you're
doing we appreciate it